the personalization pack allows you to
Brand your tungl me account with your
own logo and colors go to the public
profile dropdown and select edit
branding choose your logo from your own
files and
upload if you're happy with your logo
click save
image you can now scroll down to see a
preview of what your public profile will
look like with your own logo and color
the colors are selected by tungle based
on the logo that you
upload however you can change those by
clicking the change
Button making a new selection and
saving when you use branding not only is
your public profile branded but all
emails sent on your behalf through
tongle me are also branded with your
logo and
colors here's an example of a branded
meeting invitation
that shows the account owner's logo and
colors that they've
selected to go back to the standard
tungle logo and
colors simply click reset to default and
you're done